who always nails it in the first take
priya
and priya korea gaitin and priya okay
mankind just nails it he just nailed it
he comes in
and he's got a lot to say and he nails
it
it's fun to watch also better such a guy
absolutely
yeah i know
uh who is the last one to always leave
their trailer
you took a look i had a kind of quite a
big unit on my head that i had to take
off uh which took a little while um so i
guess out of oscar is i think i i maybe
definitely real fast oh but then you
also
also you sometimes there were some some
things that you needed to
that's oh that's true
oh yeah oh i forgot
man
which of you actually correctly guessed
where season four was going when you
started reading the scripts at the
beginning i don't remember i feel like
we all just like talked a lot about it
um together i i did not
correctly guess for sure no maybe i had
no idea
no i had no idea where it was gonna go
yeah
one of the things that matt and ross
to talk a little bit about them one of
the things that i'm just so impressed
with their writing and ability is the
way they have so many characters on this
show and everyone has a beginning middle
and end you all have journeys that you
get to go on can you sort of talk about
that aspect of their writing and the
show
it's a real
uh achievement i think for the duffers
and all of the writers to kind of
maintain this
uh this intrigue with every single
character i don't think anyone has a
kind of
a
secondary or tertiary role in it
everyone kind of has a really kind of
fleshed out
arc and for them to be able to do that
in numerous
different storylines with the yeah the
amount of characters as you said is kind
of uh and the amount of plot and the
amount of plot yeah there's like no fat
you said it really yeah it's so
streamlined it's just like
they write like they love these
characters which is like such a gift
yeah and the exposition never feels
shoehorned really because i do it and
i'm so talented you are you've given me
a second to say yeah
yeah but you know what's interesting i
never feel like when i'm watching the
show that i'm getting an exposition dump
i feel like when people are talking it's
like just part of the story you know
what it's like when you when you're
getting something like that and it takes
you out of something
yeah of course yeah you know my last
thing for for fans of stranger things
what do you think uh they would be
surprised to learn about the actual
making of the show
i don't think you'd be surprised by how
much we laugh
but we do laugh a lot a lot it's like
some real silliness goes on um
surprised
um the spores are real
yeah oh that's great
yeah the spores are not cgi no no they
are not yeah i'll never forget
finn
in season two and we're in those caves
one of those spores got into his eye and
he had an allergic reaction oh that's
why they changed and they had to like
change that sport now they're like
dandelion fluff a lot of
spores though yeah yeah
otherwise
getting your hair yeah yeah it affects
me all the time
no
on that note i gotta stop i'm just gonna
say seriously congrats the season's
fantastic you know thank you so much
you're awesome thank you thank you thank
you
you